You know this is great, greater for me.
Well, we'll be able to share a little bit of this visit with people all over the United States of America and the world.
Okay.
We certainly need to get to know who you are and what you've done. Please, tell us for starters, what is your name?
Gertrude Jackson.
And so much of what we know about you comes from what we've read in the newspapers and heard on the radio, what you did as a wife and a mother and a community activist but tell us when you were born, where you were born a little bit about what it was like to grow up where you grew up.
Okay. I was born in Madison, Illinois in 1923, and later, my daddy moved to Arkansas to take over the farm that--when his daddy died, and he came down to Arkansas to take over the farm for his mother and that's how we got to Arkansas.
How did your family come to be in Madison, Wisconsin? Where did the family start and how did you get from there to Madison, Wisconsin?
Illinois. Well, I was there--I mean, we were in Illinois, you know, when I was born. Daddy had moved to Illinois and he was working and that's where we were born, and then he came back after his father died to take over this 88-acre farm for his mother. That's why, that's what brought us back.
So how many brothers and sisters did you have there?
I had six brothers and I may have to count them--five sisters, four sisters.
Okay, can you say that again? How many brothers and sisters?
Six brothers, I have six brothers, and four sisters.
So what was it like growing up on an 88-acre cotton farm? Did you actually work?
A little because I was, mostly stayed in the house and kind of fixed them and stuff, but see, at 7 I wasn't going to be helping, but it was okay. What was it like growing up there? It was good. It was different. It was so different from Illinois, just say for instance, my first year in school was in Illinois and I see in Illinois, I was first grade, everybody had had their own room. And they had a place where you--a little room where you hang your coats and things and that was when I got to Arkansas--well, first let me back up.
In Illinois I just had to walk about a block to school, no more than that, and when I got to Arkansas, we had to walk four, five miles to school, and then you get in the school and everybody is in the same room from the first through the eighth grade. And they had little nails on the wall at the back of the room where you hang your coats, and you could take your little snack. They would sit at the back of the wall and that was just so different. It was just hard getting used to that.
That's what was strange to me when we moved to Arkansas, and the classroom's just one big room, and like, fourth through the--first through fourth grade would be on one end of the building, and fifth through eighth, they were on the other end and the big heater is right--you all know what a heater is?
Definitely know what a heater is.
So it was in the middle and that's about it. It didn't take me long to get used to it, walking. It wasn't bad but I just wasn't used to it, but it didn't take me long to catch on, okay.
So how many children were in that one-room school?
Oh, it wasn't many at that time. Back in there, no more than about maybe 60.
How many?
60.
60 children in that one room?
Right.
And how many grades?
Through the eighth. So fourth on back, we were one end and the others on the other end.
So how much schooling did you eventually have?
Eventually I got two years in college--no, three I was in college.
So--and where did you do your high school work?
Here in Marvell. At that time, Marvell only went through--Marvell only went to the 10th grade. The high school went to 10th grade here in Marvell, and this is where I got my--up to 10th grade. What you would do, you'd have to find someone to live with and just daddy would pay them rent and see if they had a woodstove, too, and they would--he had - - shop on wood, so he would put that wood in the wagon and leave my brothers bringing - - kept us wood through winter, that's how we kept warm. And that's about... I think that's about it. But--and I graduated--when you graduate, this graduation was from the 10th grade because this is as far as they went, and they had a school in Helena that went to the 12th grade, so that's where my sister went and finished.
But at the time, I finished, my mama got sick and I didn't go any farther. And then years later, at school, I got my GED. They were giving people GEDs and then years, a few years later, I was working with Mid-Delta and they said let us go to college and so I just got thirty--I was in, you know, early childhood. Okay.
When you were growing up, let's talk about your earliest years in Illinois, and then in Arkansas. When you were growing up, do you remember instances of outright flagrant discrimination?
No, I don't. But did you say in Illinois or just all over everywhere?
Let's just start with Illinois. Do you remember?
No, I don't remember any.
Nothing in Illinois?
No.
And Arkansas, your early years in Arkansas?
I just noticed the schools, you know, different schools were... It was different.
That's good. Describe for me the difference between the schools, between the schools that you were allowed to attend and the schools that--what's the difference?
Oh, okay. Well, there's a lot of difference. How can I explain that? We were in this one-room school like I say, I already explained that, and then they were--the other schools, the white schools, just beautiful and all together, and the white children rode the bus to school but we walked. And that was the difference.
And one thing that brought to mind when you said that, we'd be walking to school and the white--the bus passed us, there's a boy on the other side of the metal and he'd be passing by and he'd say "nigger, nigger, nigger, nigger, nigger," so one day, a boy got--he was waiting for him and the boy stepped on the ditch and he got him a stick, so the feller put his hand out of the window and said "nigger, nigger," he popped him, and after that they never--they had the window rolled up when they'd come through.
So I'm quite sure there were many times when you and your pals, your childhood friends would go home to your parents and your uncles and aunts and tell stories like that. What did they say to you in response to how you were to respond to that?
To what I just said?
Yeah, when there were moments when people called you nasty names and were mean to you and you would go home to adults and say--what kind of advice did they give you about responding?
I never really experienced being--something happened at school like that, because I was just - - I didn't mettle.
There was a newspaper report not too long ago. It talked about how one of your daughters has said that she wanted to be white so she could have--
So when I got upset with her, and like the spirit say, I asked her why--it came to me just like that. And I said, now why do you want to be white? So we can have some swings and some seesaws and have a pretty school, and see, if I had cut her off I never would have known her reason. And she said it's since she'd been grown, that was the pretty school. Oh, yes, and we could have some swings and seesaws and we didn't have any of that, just the naked ground, just nothing. And of course we had invented our own - - games and like that.
So the first time you heard her say that, how did you feel?
I felt like--white? Why do you want to be white? But then after she explained, I said... Then I found out it wasn't white--it's what, the things they had. MALE VOICE 1: Mrs. Jackson, do you think you could tell that story from the beginning?
I was just about to ask that. Figure out a way to--
I think that's the beginning. What I just said? MALE VOICE 1: Yeah, talk about how your daughter came to you so everyone at home will be able to hear it from the very beginning.
Oh. I was in the kitchen cooking and she's just standing round, and she said "I wish I was white." And I stopped, kind of like--didn't like it. And I said, well--the spirit said ask her why. And that's what she told me--so I can have some swings, and seesaws, and go to the pretty school and... She said it was the prettiest place, and see, we didn't have swings and seesaws at our school. But to make a long story short, she wanted to be in that pretty school, and wanted to have some swings and seesaws.
So how did that story influence your life and what you were doing, your life's work?
Well, really at that time, I didn't dwell it. It just kind of passed through, because you know, I knew that's the way it was.
So you spent so much of your life in the area of community organizing. What motivated you? How did you get started doing that?
I think the first thing that motivated me, if I can kind of tell, explain the Marvell school district, okay, the Marvell school district covers like, oh... 20 miles around. And there were a school--okay, we had so many schools out in the--see, I grew up in Gum Bottom. Somebody grew up in Coffers Creek [phonetic]--there was a school everywhere, where there was a church there was a school. And then the Marvell school district years later decided to build a school down there for--and about six of the communities came together, went to this one school.
It was a beautiful school, but what happened after three or four years, the sewage start messing up, and the sewage would back up in the school so at first it was just water and they would come on and say "Oh, the bathroom flooded today," and see, I wasn't paying it much attention. The bathroom flooded, and it would come on--it got where it got so bad, everything was flooding out and the boys had to clean it up. They'd get them - - from the store, the boys had to get the boxes and things and clean it up, so we decided to go to the school board.
That's where I got started, went to the school board to tell them about it, and they would say, "Oh, they just don't know how to use the bathroom." And so it went on so long, they'd come home from playing so long, so regular, my husband said "I'm going to go out there and see this thing." And so we had gone to the school board for several times and they just wouldn't do anything, just felt like we didn't know how to use the bathroom at all.
And the last time we went to the school board and my husband asked them about fixing it again, - - just my husband and another lady, she's passed away, but coming from the school board that night, my husband said, "If I could get these people to take the children out of school, they'd fix it." That man got up the next morning and went all through the community and was telling them about it, and everybody agreed to take their children out, and so that's the first boycott, turn at boycott, and when we did, so they went down the next day. This was on a Friday--we'd come that Monday, my husband went down to the school to see what was going on.
He said well, I forget how many children they had, but eight or ten children showed up at school, and so after that--and it just stayed vacant until they didn't get to school at all that year.
Let me get the timeframe for this. What year was the first year that you went to the school board to complain?
You know, I... I really can't remember. I know my... You know, I just don't remember because let me see - - went to that school when he was 5. Now, if we could do some math...
We'll figure that out later.
You're right--figure that out later, okay.
Now, your husband went through the community basically knocking on doors and asking parents to keep their children at home.
Right.
Everyone unanimously said "Yes, we will keep the children"--
Right, and what he did- -now, we had this country store. There would be a lot of men at the store. That's how he reached a lot of them, and then they--he took them down there and let them see for themselves and everybody went down and looked and that Monday morning, they kept the children at home.
And how did the school board officials respond?
Some of them said--some of the people said, "Somebody needs to go there and whoop that Hog Jackson." They called my husband Hog--that somebody needs to go there and whoop him, but they didn't bother us. It was fine.
So did they call you--what happened after that? How did it get to be fine? Did they call you in for meetings?
Oh, no, they just... I don't know what--when we went to court. We didn't go to court for that, but after we walked out of school and they send people down--well, what happened, they were going to send somebody down to see about the plumbing. And so come to see the president of the school, his brother was--what do you call it, sanitation thing in Helena, so they send someone down to see how it was when we took the children out of school. And so the superintendent said there wasn't nothing wrong with it and so we wanted to have it checked, so they called a feller, whoever you call that came out and checked it, and he said, "Oh, it's fine. Nothing wrong with the bathroom.
It's fine." But see, that was his brother that checked it, and see, Howard was here at that time, and Howard called the sanitation place from Little Rock, and they came down and checked it out, and they made them dig it up, and do it over because it was put up--it was put in going up here, and that's why the bathroom was messing up. And they fixed it and we got back in school. I guess it lasted...
How long were the children out of school?
I think they were out, like--I remember, I forget what month it was but they were out, like, near the whole term.
We'll have to do some--I'll have to get that schedule. That's fine; it's a beautiful story. FEMALE VOICE 1: Were there any stories in the newspapers about it?
No, we didn't. Newspapers never... FEMALE VOICE 1: We can probably check the board of education records.
Yeah, I made a note, too--
If they did, we didn't know about it. FEMALE VOICE 1: Okay.
Okay, I made a note to fit it-- FEMALE VOICE 1: You said your son was five years old when he attended the school--he was five?
That's what I was trying to figure out--I don't know if he was 6. FEMALE VOICE 1: If he was 6 in first grade--when was he born? In 19...
He was born in 1945, Pop was born in '47--I don't mean, what am I saying, '40?
Yeah, you are, but-- MALE VOICE 1: That's right.
Is that right? FEMALE VOICE 1: We can find out.
We'll find it out. FEMALE VOICE 1: We'll find out when he was born.
Okay. FEMALE VOICE 1: And that will give us a year.
Okay.
Tell us what you remember about the children talking about the work that they actually had to do to clean up after the bathroom flooded.
Mine was too little at that time to do it, but the bigger boys did--you know, the big children, they had to do it. And they'd talk about it at first it's just water. I wished--I was trying to get ahold of these couple old boys still living, I wish I could have got them to tell the story about how they used to have to clean up the bathroom, mop up water and all that, and get - - old boxes from the store to, you know, put stuff in. I wished I had one of them here because they'd tell that story.
We'll probably find one. Let's move a little bit forward and talk about your work in the freedom movement. When you first heard that there were people who were doing work in the civil rights arena, what did you think?
You know what? Now, the workers came in. They came into the family, stayed, had a meeting with the family here in town, so see, I lived 12 miles out and they came and they said some--we're civil rights workers. It's down in Mr. Adam's house, and Mr. Adam wanted him to bring some people in that may be interested and four or five of us went to this meeting and listened to what they had to say. And to make a long story short, we got some work on - - the first--back up.
First of all--
That's how we went there to talk with them and then they asked us to go back and get a group together and some interested people and we came back and checked with some people in our community, which was called Jones Ridge and we had six or seven people to meet and they'd come down to tell us what they were all about.
Let me take you back a little bit. Tell us exactly who Mr. Adams is.
He's just a neighbor. He's a farmer. He ran the store, and he was one of the people that kind of would be--I'd call a civil rights worker. I don't know. We hadn't heard talk of anything but they said come here, it's a man, it's somebody here from the civil rights and he wants to talk to us.
And what's Mr. Adams'--what's his whole name?
Overtis [phonetic]. Overtis Adams.
And do you remember the names of any of the people who came from other parts of the country to--?
- - You know, it's about two of them still living--Eva May Williams and a brother, I forget his name but he's a Williams, might think of it before we leave.
But so Eva May Williams was someone who came from--
Oh, no, she lived in school district, but she's the one that, you know, when we come together to do something about the school situation, because she was the secretary.
Now... I'm sorry, I thought I stepped on one of your sentences. I'm sorry. Now, there were SNCC workers who were working in the area.
Right. Mm-hmm.
What do you remember about the SNCC workers? Do you remember their names, where they came from?
Myrtle Glascoe and Howard Himmelbaum. And so once we got visited, you know, they were here a while before anything, we started to do anything, but just kind of got to feel and we would meet and they'd always have a building full, a church full to come out and hear what we were doing and what we were trying to do and after so long, he said now, you all do it yourself now, but they would just be there. He didn't want to be the leader all the time, and that's about that.
So do you remember any other names of SNCC workers?
Nancy Lane, William Lane [phonetic]... So many of them are gone, because not many of them are left so it's hard to think. MALE VOICE 1: We're talking about the people who came from out of town.
Oh, those are the ones you want--those two.
So what was the atmosphere like? What was the mood like when those SNCC meetings were going on here in the area?
You know, it was just kind of nice. We'd have a packed church every Thursday night. And so we just made it--come on, ask me.
So the people who did come from out of town, where did they live? Where did they eat?
Some of them, the first place they lived was my uncle, Howard Himmelbaum, he lived with my uncle and they had a place in Helena that they stayed but my uncle kept them for a while until he got nervous because he had a store and his house was right by the store and they didn't want white folks to see him coming out of his house so then he moved, he moved way back and lived with my cousin Carrie--Carrie Davis [phonetic] at that time. But he had to walk a couple miles back to the mud and stuff to get over there, and so we said, well, won't nobody find him back there because if he just comes out on the porch and opened the door, the store was right there, even with the house and stuff. We didn't want him.
Then my uncle got real nervous about having this white man living with him. He didn't stay with him long--maybe a month, and he moved back down where he couldn't be found and walk out every day, come by the house and we eat and all. I'm thinking they also had a place in Helena where they could live. Come on, ask.[background noise]
Okay. You mean a paper?
Tell us the name of the gentleman who stayed with your uncle.
Howard Himmelbaum.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
What else do you remember about him?
Well, you know, we got so comfortable, one thing we did, we got a little too comfortable with him and he'd come to the house and he'd eat and sit round with my children, go out together, you know where you go to your little cafe or wherever people--and they would go out together and it was just like, we just got very comfortable with it and so--and we were blessed that didn't anything happen to us. And I remember one day, when they built the Zachariah [phonetic] housing project and the president--I mean, what do you call it? Who's of the state?
Governor.
Governor--governor, right. The governor came down that day and a lot of people to show off, you know, they were opening up the housing project and so Howard was there, so the superintendent of the school, he stepped to me. "Gertrude, who is he? Who is that?" I make like I couldn't find--"no, that right there, right there." I said "Oh, that's Howard Himmelbaum."
Do you remember anyone else in addition to Handelbaum?
Myrtle Glascoe.
Okay, talk about--
It's just those two.
Talk a little bit about Myrtle Glascoe. What do you remember about her?
What I remember about Myrtle? Well, she'd come to the house and they'd just say things, they'd just--just like another one of my 11 children. And just remember her, just point something, up and come into the house and sit right at the table with all my 10 children and like I say, just like another daughter, she would go to the meetings with us and you know, they would explain different things about civil rights and things like that.
So what did they encourage the people attending the meetings to do?
You know, just stand up and be bold and let's get something done.
And can you remember the names of the people living in the community who stood up and said yes, we're going to be bold? Do you remember people who actually joined the movement and worked very hard?
Let me... It wasn't very many that worked very hard, but most of them saw what we were doing, and then see, some of them were too afraid and they just stayed back but they would come to the meetings and listen, and I can't think of the names of the people--about six of them were, you know, standing back, giving us, you know, spinning their ideas and things. And so--but like I say, most of them were afraid and we knew the teachers were afraid, and we didn't want them to be in the meetings because we didn't want them to lose their jobs.
What about others who were afraid? How did they explain their fear?
Now, this one man, - - told my husband--he said, Jack, don't fault what you're doing, but I can't join. He said Jack, I'm just scared. I'm just scared. I won't go with you but I'm for what you're doing. And other than that, that's about it.
And do you remember what people said to people who were afraid to get them to step out of their fear and be bold?
No, I don't remember anybody bothering them. It was just a few little - - come to those meetings. Now, one thing that happened down in my country, Maxine Hathaway was one of the schoolteachers here in Marvell, and you know, on Sundays if we were in church, after Sunday school we're going to say something about the situation. And so different people told her, "Girl, you better stop going to the church. Tell me they have civil rights meetings down at that church." And so she left our church and went to the church where they didn't meet, came here to Marvell and went to church.
So once you became involved, there were moments of... There were repercussions. White people did not like what you were doing. How did they respond to you?
Well, not really, but I'll tell you one day I was in the drugstore, and the lady that worked at the drugstore--by the way, she's in a nursing home now. But anyway, this white man was in there, and I was getting my medicine and she said to me, she said, "There she is, there she is, there she is," like they were trying to find out who was that that was doing the civil rights work and so that's the only thing that I saw.
And did anyone say anything to you once you were pointed out?
No, they just--I guess the feller just wanted to see what I looked like, just wanted to see that lady that's heading civil rights.
So do you remember instances of other people having crosses burned in their yards or gunshots fired?
Overtis Adams had a cross--not Overtis. This is way out in the country. I can't think of his name right now, but they burned a cross in his yard and then John Hamilton, he's one of the leaders. He's one of the big leaders that was with us--John Hamilton and his wife.
What do you remember about the time that the cross was burned?
I just remember that the children--we were just excited, didn't know--we didn't know what it meant, but my daughter was talking. They were talking some time ago--all we know, that when somebody burns a cross in the yard the white folks didn't like you, so she said that's all she can get out of it. Then she noticed some reason the white folks didn't like you.
Were there black folks who tried to respond to that in a retaliatory way?
No, no we didn't do anything, just kept going on like it didn't happen.
And how many cases of cross burnings do you know of?
Just two. One in Masco Anderson [phonetic]. Now, John Hamilton, it got in the air because he was the main person along with my husband, John Hamilton--it got in the air that--and he lived way back off the road--that a gang had planned to come and you know, attack them that night. And so what the men did was about 10 or 12 men, they met down there with their guns, because this man is way back, had to go down the field to get to his house and they went there and stayed all night to see if anybody was coming in, because one of the boys said now if they come driving out through here I'm going to blow them away, so that's the incident there.
Let's talk about newspapers for a little bit. Did the newspapers cover--did they write stories about the civil rights activity going on down here?
No. No, we didn't--no, it was never in the news. Now... What was in the news--well, it wasn't here, but Beatrice, our executive director, she was going to school in Little Rock, and she would read it there and then just talk about Jackson and she heard some things. She was here, but she was sitting around talking about it at school in Little Rock, and...
How much conversation was there about the activity happening just a stone's throw away in Little Rock? There was a difference--
Say that again.
So the people who lived in this area, outside of Little Rock, did they play close attention to what was--
Yes, they did. Uh-huh.
What kind of conversations did they have about Little Rock activity?
Well, just discuss the situation and--it wasn't very much because... And oh, like my children were so little because I remember they were so little because okay, every time the news came on they had to be quiet, so this news came on they were showing in Little Rock, you know, going in the school and the club and things. My little girl said, "Oh, the news is good tonight," because she was excited--she just didn't know what it was all about. But that's all we saw the few times, you know, when it would come on the TV about what was going on. My husband didn't have to say "You all be quiet--the news is on." Oh, it got quiet.
So did you and your husband spend any time telling your children exactly what was going on?
Exactly what was going on, yes.
How did you explain to your children what was going on in Little Rock?
I just told them it's just like it is here in Marvell- whites go to one school and so now they're trying to integrate them and let blacks go to the school, and the fight was about because they didn't want them in their school and that's why they had to bring down the troops and all these things.
And how did your children respond to that story?
Well, kind of like they already knew because it's just like, it was here, you know? You see what I'm saying? We were going--the whites were going to the big school down here and we were going to the little chicken coops.
Tell us about the moment when there's an issue about the county fair.[laughter]
It wasn't really an issue about the county fair, but this is the way it happened: We decided to boycott the school and so Reverend Anderson, the man with the burned cross in the yard, he's at the meeting. He said I'll tell you all what, since we're boycotting school, let's boycott that fair, and they said yeah, and that's how we come to boycott the fair. And another thing about the fair, the superintendent, you know, - - in college in Pine Bluff, that's a black college at that time. The superintendent, the choir from - - College was coming down to sing at the choir, and we heard that--we were in Little Rock at this trial about this boy. You know, we had to go to trial, we had to go to court, so we were in Little Rock, so Mrs.
Hamilton on our way back home, she said let's go by the college and tell them don't come down to sing because we're boycotting everything. So we went back and talked with them, and the superintendent was out of town. They said he would have to change it; we can't change it. But anyway, they came on down to sing and then I got another lady that we just, we said let's go to the fair and see how it's going to come out so we went to the fair and just parked out from--in the ditch about the fair, and it worked. People didn't come. I saw some little children come, saw some little white boys--they'd come around. They had heard something. They didn't know what--some little black boys, too.
Oh, they say you ain't supposed to go to fair today, they'd be--and they'd just run, just running, and it was just... It was just nothing going on because nobody came. But the college choir came down, this big bus came down and children got off and they washed up the bleachers, they sing like they had a crowd but it wasn't sold there. And see, the fair didn't make any money that year. So that's what happened with that. And it was just interesting, too. You know, some things just motivate you--once you get started, you want to reach at something else.
Could we take a break for a second? MALE VOICE 1: Sure.
We're going to take a break for a second.
Okay. MALE VOICE 1: - - They boycotted the fair--
Oh, my lord. MALE VOICE 1: - - Sister, I didn't hear the part that it impacted whites accidentally because they heard the story. They didn't have all the information, but they ended up not going to the fair as well. Do you remember the year that that was?
Oh... Didn't nobody go to--it was - - but to me, I looked out there and it's just empty, except you know, the little stuff they have set up out there. And then-- FEMALE VOICE 1: Was it before the civil rights workers had come or after?
No, after. MALE VOICE 1: Okay, so they came in 1963, '64, so it would have been after that.
Okay...[break in audio]
--Some hair-raising details about crosses being burned on other people's yards. Don't you know someone else who has had a cross burned?
No, just my yard and just Reverend Masco Anderson.
Tell us about the cross being burned in your yard.
Well, like I say, the children going have to go to school and they saw it. It was like, what they did, they burned the shape of a cross in the grass and we all just went out and looked at it, and the grown people knew what it was like, what it was about, but my daughter was telling me lately, she said see, out here you all are whispering, you all--you know, we didn't sit down and really explain to them. We hear you all talking but all I know, they said when they burn a cross in your yard, it was because white folks--something about white folks didn't like you if you got a cross burned in your yard so that's what she was telling me.
So how did it affect you?
I guess I was--what's that that people take to make them strong and bolder, these athletes--I guess I was on a high, and I was just fine with it, because--just had a little fight in me and just ready to go on. But it didn't stop us. And then before that then, I don't know which comes first--it doesn't matter. When they set the shop on fire where we keep the tractors and trucks and things, my daughter went out on the porch one night to do something, and she looked up and she said, "The shop's on fire" and boy, everybody jumped to attention then. My husband had gone to bed. I said, the man must have been expecting somebody to attack him. He jumped out of the bed so quick that he didn't even put on his shoes.
So he went out there and the truck--the tractor was out there, so what he did, he found the log chain, what old chain he had, hooked to a tractor, then hooked it to the truck, pulled the truck out across the field, and that's where the truck burned up, and what had happened, somebody had stuck a rag or something down in the gas tank and set it, set the rag on fire, and that's what was burning, so--but anyway, it caught the truck. Now, if we hadn't seen it, it probably would have got the tractors and everything else. Pulled it out across the field and that's where it burned up. And like, we didn't put no papers in there, so we weren't doing stuff like that. FEMALE VOICE 1: And Miss Jackson, wasn't there also an incidence where they put sugar in the--
Yeah, in the cotton picker. They didn't lock up--he was working some land way away from home and when they get through, they just leave it in the field until they get back, so his brother went to the field that morning to, you know, pick cotton. He said before I got there I could see some tracks, looked like four tractor tracks, so he said, somebody's been up here sniffing my--getting gas out of his tank so that's what he put it to. And he got up there and got on the cotton picker, he says I got halfway down, piece down through the field, it stopped. And they said you can put sugar in the tank and that will lock up everything but they don't know what made it happen, but it locked up and they didn't have no cotton picker.
But James, the brother was a good mechanic, you know, - - mechanic on himself, and they fixed it.
Did you ever know who did it?
Never knew who did it.
There's also an instance, a case of shots being fired at you. Is that true?
Okay. I guess this is what my grandson is saying. I was going home from work one day and this truck pulled up and it was coming but when it got close to me it slowed down. When it slowed down, some kind of flash went over me, that's the first time something--I felt uncomfortable. They followed me just a little while and after a while, the driver must have changed his mind--the driver pulled off and sped by me but when he sped by, the man on the passenger side had his little pistol. He shot right across in front of the hood of my car. And I wouldn't tell my husband because I knew he was going to get out and try to find who did it and I didn't want him putting himself in danger like that.
It was a long time before I told him; didn't tell any of them, because I go to work every day. He would have been thinking about me going to work every day.
What year was that?
I'm just so sorry. I don't know.
Did you tell anybody?
Later on, about maybe a month or so later. I told him about it and...
Had you heard of things like that happening to other people? Did other people tell you about things like that happening to them?
I heard about the things in Mississippi, you know, the little boy that got killed and stuff like that, and then, well, after that, the civil rights workers in Mississippi got killed. I think Myrtle told you about that, or did she?
How did you respond to that?
I knew they were letting me know they didn't like what I was doing, and then I knew I wasn't going to stop doing what I was doing, and that's about it.
Wow. Was there any time when your husband came to you with any kind of thoughts that he was having reservations about doing what he was doing?
You know, he never did. He would just get up there - - and be prepared to do what we had to do for - -.
Not a moment of fear?
I don't remember him talking about being afraid or nothing. But I know one--I can say this: To get to one of our farms we had to drive through the white man's property, and so the man told him, three of them told him don't come back through there and for a long time they went like, six or seven miles out of the way to get to the field when they could get to it like, 30 minutes directly. And so one day he came in, he had done that for a long time, I guess maybe a couple years before. But anyway, when he left one day he said, well, I'm gone. And he had his pistol--the first time I ever saw him get his pistol. He said they might get me today, but I think I can get some of them.
At least I think I can get some of them, and I think that's when he broke the thing about going through this man's field, didn't nobody ever bother him, though.
How did you feel when he said that to you, they might get me?
Well, I can't explain it but you know... In my heart it felt like they ain't going to get him, but he walked out with his little--his called it his little piece. And that's the first time he ever met--they might get me today, but I think I can get some of before they--because you know, they're not going to come at you one-on-one. There's always going to be a crowd when they come after you.
One second. Are we going to film at the community center?[background conversation]
Say something about the center? MALE VOICE 1: The community center.
Mm-hmm.
First of all, just describe--tell me what motivated you to start a community center.
Well, like I say, I wasn't thinking about it. I was sitting at my desk, see, Mid-Delta was - - and I was sitting at my desk and it just dropped in by spirit and all it said was something for children and it stayed there like, like a couple months, just something for children, just something within, until one morning Mr. Gale Thrower, the Ag teacher, came to my office and he says, Miss Jackson, I see you all have a room back there that you're not using. And he said you know how the children haven't got anywhere to go, and I would like to fix it up, you know, where the children have something to--and I said, boy, God must have sent you here and we got started from there.
His thing was - - my thing was education, because I wanted more head starts--I wanted every child in the district to have seen a book before they go to school. And what I did that year, retired teachers, I had about two--Maxine Hathaway, Anna May Smith, and by me--I used to haul, pick up children, take them to head start. Then I knew where everybody was, and I went to different houses like Mrs. Hathaway, took about three houses to just go and read a book. I said you all are all I want, I want to let every child see a book before you go to school you see. You know, we just did--that wasn't our culture, so when I found the families for, and they went to these families that read stories--did the same thing we do at head start.
And Maxine Hathaway and Anna May Smith and Beatrice, I think Beatrice, the executive director did one. But anyway, that's what I wanted--I said you all are going to see every child that's going to school to have seen a book before they go, and that's what we did. They would take the little their little paint and everything just like we did at head start, put the easel, the tree where it would be an easel and they would do their little painting and stuff and just read little stories to them because you would be surprised that the people never saw a book when they go to school. So that's what I wanted, and I wanted them to have these shots because there were so many children that didn't go to school because you don't have those shots, you can't go to school.
And it's so hard for them to get, like, 30 miles, you know, out there all the time and so what we did, I got--after these teachers, these ladies did the home start and of course I was doing one too. And what we did about the shots, just come down, the nurses from Helena would come down to this big raggedy center where it was - - and they gave shots. They would come down and give them shots, and then after we got, after we founded BGACDC, then they got a grant and they built a building onto it, and the staff would come from Helena, and that's how they got everything. They did everything there. They do everything there that they did in Helena.
So describe the building before you tweaked in massaged it and polished it to turn it into the community center. What did it look like?
It looked pretty good except there wasn't no roof, there wasn't no...And of course, there wasn't any ceiling. That's most of what this--Channel 2 came down and took pictures of that and what we were doing.
There was no roof?[background noise]
Well--[audio ends abruptly]
See, I worked in Helena a while, and that's how I got at the center. You're not taping?Wait, I'm not ready right now. You know, you've got to help me out some. MALE VOICE 1: You're doing justfine. You're great. Okay, we're rolling again. We're rolling.
Okay. When you got the idea to start working on a community center, you were already working with children.
Mm-hmm.
In what--with what agency?
Mid-Delta. Mid-Delta Community Service.
And tell us a little bit about Mid-Delta Community Service. What did you do there?
The first job I had with Mid-Delta was transporting children to head start, go all--I guess I would do like, maybe 40 miles in the morning, 40 in the evening, going picking up children, going across the fields in different communities, just knocking on the doors and see who was there for head start.
So how many children did you transport?
15--20, 15 in one room, 15 in another so that's 30 children. And we always had to make a couple of trips. And that was--it was kind of not so nice, but I had the station. The gentleman had been out to my house to ask me if I'd do it. They thought I was the only person that they could find in the district that had a station wagon, and they came down and asked me would I pick up the children for head start. My husband said you can't do that. She's rolling all over this country--so we turned it down, a little fly on your paper.[laughter] MALE VOICE 1: Yeah, I don't think the fly filled out a release form, so...
Priceless.[laughter]
But anyway, they couldn't find anybody and they came back again and so he says go on, and so that's the first job I had for Mid-Delta was transporting children. And from there, teaching head start.
Do any of--tell us a little bit about some of the children who were standouts for you, the children that you will remember for the rest of your life there at that community center.
Now you're talking about the head start children?
Start with the head start children and talk about the children from your community center. Were there any that--?
No, nothing that really stood out.
Nobody that touched your heart in a special way because they...?
Well, I tell you, I just thought about this little boy. He's a twin and in head start he was so disrupted. You know when you get upset, he would get up and go around and seat--we sit in a circle, like semicircle. He'd get up and go around and tap everybody on the head, hit them and what I want to get to--he'd get upset and he'd go around and knock the work off the wall. But it came to, we found out that he wasn't coming from a comfortable home. We think that was part of it and so, like when I would take him for field trips, take him for a walk and stuff like that to cool him off, and so that's about--I'd get his name.
He's someone that really stood out, and we had to visit, do home visits and we found out--and talked to the parents, so... We had him two years because if you come at 4, you could be there two years. And that's about it. MALE VOICE 1: Stop for a moment.
Mm-hmm.
That one. FEMALE VOICE 1: - -
See, I thought I better bring somebody. Okay, I used to--like you said, picking up children and one family lived on this white man's place and I had to go down like a little road to get to it, a little turn road, and I'd go there and pick up, so one day I went to pick her up and she'd have met me out on the highway with her little boy. I said, what are you doing out here? Our boss told us--the man's place they stay on--our boss told us to tell that lady that's driving that white station wagon to stay off his place because I don't want nobody on my place that has something to do with that Martin Luther King.
And so she said but don't worry, we're going to get off his place, and what impressed me was maybe in a little better than a year, it was better than a year, they had bought up and built their own house and it's good they got me off of that because after that, I was--moved to head start teacher, home start. That's where you go into the home and teach them. You do the same thing in the home that you did in school, and so I said now it's good they got off his place because when I got to be home start teacher, I had to take all my stuff with me and then once a month we'd have a parent meeting and all the houses would meet together in one house.
I said it would have been some black folks moving out, going through the turn road to his field--I said, well, they moved off just in time, so it was just great. Now, that's all I had--I really had forgotten about that one. And the other words, you know-- MALE VOICE 1: - - FEMALE VOICE 1: But finish your thought.
Now, where was I? Now, I say it was good I moved off the place because from head start, picking up the children I had to do home start and that's where you go into the home and carry all your materials and do all the same things you do at school. I said now, if he hadn't put me off this place because like I think I had ten houses that I'd go to but once a month I was required to bring them all together and have a parent meeting, somebody from the main office would come down and do things and I said now, that would have been awful, had they still been on his place because he sure wouldn't want all of us coming back there to a meeting. Even sometimes like at 12 o'clock, the men would come out to feed them.
They'd just enjoy, to come out the field and where the head start was and see what we were doing, so we enjoyed--so TJ, I'm glad you made me think of it.
Yes, thank you, TJ. Do you have another one? MALE VOICE 1: No. It just comes up.
I want to go way back. Your father's birthplace fascinates me, where he chose--where was your father born?
In Arkansas.
Why did he leave Arkansas?
Heard that the grass is greener on the other side of the fence, you know, for a job went there and he worked at the commonwealth- what do you call it? Commonwealth... It was a factory that he worked at. They called it Commonwealth.
So what was his life like here in Arkansas?
He was a farmer.
He was a farmer?
And someone, some of the people started going south and they told him about, you know, and he liked what they said, and he went up there to try it.
Okay. Your children and your children's children and everyone who knows them will know a little bit about the work that you and your husband did in the movement.
Right.
They'll know a little bit. They'll never know all of it, but what would you say would be the most important thing they need to know about the work you did in the movement?
Things that they would need to know? Except stand up for yourself, and you know... Get involved. If the need ever comes, you know... I'd like to encourage them to make sure they go to PTA meetings and things like that because right now we have so many parents--it's not like it used to be, see, it's hard to get parents to attend the school system. And then--
We're going to have to wait.[background conversation]
And let me know when I'm doing something wrong, because if I hit the paper, I didn't know that was wrong, so let me know when. MALE VOICE 1: You're doing wonderfully.
Doing all right, okay.[background conversation] MALE VOICE 1: - - Okay. Okay, do you want to ask that question again?
We're going to ask the question again. You gave it a beautiful start, but we lost the end of it to the noise, so what would you like, not just your--
Okay. Well, with the start, they were children, some had already gone off to school, like, well, like the four older ones had gone when the civil rights movement, and I just would like want to be involved, which most of them are doing, being involved with the schools and whatever.
All right, wonderful. Thank you so much. We are going to go over to your community center.
Okay, because I didn't know what to expect, because like I've been to places and I had to just talk, just tell them what I'd done and so when I had put together the different... Let me see if I missed anything that I had planned, but you - - right, so--
No. FEMALE VOICE 1: - - That's fine. [break in audio]
You all going to do it. Okay, I guess I'll sit straight and... MALE VOICE 1: - - Okay.
School integration, when they wouldn't--when the school system was ordered to integrate and the integration was to be done, like, three years, the first year they were going to do it through the third grade. Then the next year they were going to take the grades four through eight. Now, they went on and obeyed the first year, the children, and I guess no more than ten or twelve children, black people--that was such an awful way to integrate, send you choose whether you want to go back to your school or go to the white school, that's what we had to choose. And so the next year it was going to be the fourth through the eighth, and that's when they--my husband called. That's when they balked, they decided, uh-uh, no way, we just can't go no further.
And so the choice for them--if you don't get a choice for them, don't go to school at all because first we had planned to march, take the children over there and okay, can I start over?
Sure.
Okay. Now, at a meeting one night, Myrtle decided that if we could just take our children over there, since they wouldn't send us the choice form. We'd just go anyway, and they had heard that we were coming, somebody leaked out of the meeting somehow, and got to the other folk and they were prepared for us. They covered their school, the whole block around the school with--it was cars, trucks were bumper to bumper, two, three men on each truck. You know these trucks have rifle racks on them, and so the lady said, they heard that you all are going to walk--you know, walk to school, going to come onto school this morning, and they were all prepared for you this morning, prepared. And so my cousin, she was braver than I, crazier than I was, however you want to call it.
But we said let's go and we drove around there and it was just like she said--from Irving garage [phonetic] all the way around to the bus shop, trucks were bumper to bumper with two, three men on each one of them, waiting for us when we come through the mud, and I don't know what they plan to do, but that's the way it was. And I would like say, when we were boycotting, we had the church--we met at my church. They set up a little library and bought books and things so we could do something while they were out of the school--the children would go down to the church and read books and things like that. That's all.
Like Myrtle said now, the children got to have something while they're out of school, so we were out of school quite a few months there, so at least we can meet and read books and whatever we know verbally. And I guess... MALE VOICE 1: Do you want to go further with that, the trucks waiting - - oh, okay. I'm just wondering what happened next.
We're going to have to continue that story, okay? We're going to talk about what happened next, and then how that--what happened next took us to the court action.
Right, okay. I guess I have to get... Okay, then Mr. Handelbaum said now, we agreed that we wanted to go to court. He said now, but we've got to have somebody that you know, can't send them all to school. We've got to have somebody. So my husband said, well, I'll do it, and that's how it got started with him, because you know, there wasn't anybody else that wanted to, was willing to go to court for the school, so he said he would do it.
So describe some of the activity of the court. You went to the courtroom?
Mm-hmm, we had to be there.
Yeah. What was that like?
It was interesting. It was neat. I could say this, we had a good judge that after a couple of days he ordered them to integrate.
And who was the judge?
Owen Harris [phonetic]. Mm-hmm, because he'll be in some of those papers, but Owen Harris was the judge and once he decided, come made his decision, he ordered them to integrate and one thing he said, there will no longer be two buses riding down the same route, one bus will pick up white and black and the school board, they like to jump out of their seats and that's about it. John Walker [phonetic] was our lawyer.
What was John Walker like?
Real nice. He was just coming, just had got his--and he had it together. He had just come out of college or law school or whatever, but he did good. He was doing great.
Do you remember what he would say in the courtroom during this case?
You know, I sure don't.
Okay.
Those things - - he would do things like, "Well, you know, the nigger" so the judge, then Walker would have him say it right instead of having him say nigger. That was just kind of funny to me. Every time they'd go out of place he'd correct them. But I really enjoyed the judge, because he ordered them--there would be no problem in Marvell. He said I'd go to any price to see that there would be no problem in Marvell.
And what was the response in the courtroom from--?
It's just us and there wasn't any audience. But they like to jump out their seat--they jumped and looked at each other, and so when we went on back to school, the buses, they had to stop at them, because you see, maybe a white person living here and then a black person there would see that one bus would come through to pick up the whites and then there's a black bus and a white bus. And we used to watch for the school buses--let me know when the bus coming. They'd just say "the bus coming" and they'd say "white or black?" And one day my son said--[background noise]
What is that? One day my son says, when they say "the bus coming," "white or black?" he said "yellow."[applause] FEMALE VOICE 1: That was fabulous.
Do we need to do that again? MALE VOICE 1: I think it's okay.
You think? MALE VOICE 1: Yeah. FEMALE VOICE 1: Because it was fabulous. MALE VOICE 1: I mean, she could tell it again. Why don't you have her tell it again?
Just for--can you do that last statement again, when your son said--
About the bus?
Uh-huh.
Well it used to be, you know, like, two buses, one bus for the white children and one for the black children, and when we--somebody's always watching for the bus to let us know when it's coming and then they say "The bus coming." "White or black?" We kept up that a long time, so one day they ask him, "bus coming, white--which one?" He said, "yellow."
Okay.
"White or black?" "Yellow."
All right. I think we should go to the community center. MALE VOICE 1: Okay.
Okay? MALE VOICE 1: All right.
But I'm glad I thought of that one.
Do you want anything wrapped up before? FEMALE VOICE 1: I think we need to--
I think so, yeah. FEMALE VOICE 1: And that would be great if we could put it--
Uh-huh. FEMALE VOICE 1: And we could actually see the center that she founded.
Oh, but you can't see it as I found it because we did something about it. FEMALE VOICE 1: That's okay. It's still the place. Because it--[break in audio] REVEREND JEROME TURNER: --Poplar Grove, Arkansas, that's a few miles east of Marvell, Arkansas and it's located in the county of Phillips, Arkansas and it's close to the Mississippi River, close to Helena, West Helena area, and that's what I do here at BGACDC, and of course BGACDC stands for Boys Girls Adult Community Development Center. I am the youth and family director here at BGACDC.
And what kind of activities go on here in this--
Well, we have three--four component areas in which we have activities here at BGACDC. Of course, those four component areas are we have youth and family services, we have an economic development area, and of course we have housing, and of course there's an administrative area, but in housing we have what we call the BGACDC Manor which is a family dwelling. It's for low-income housing project, and at that location there are some one, two and three-bedroom units and it is our housing project for the city of Marvell. We also have some standalone housing, some units that are operated by the BGACDC and they are rental property housing at BGACDC, so one of our goals here is to provide decent and affordable housing for low-income families and so we do that through that dwelling of family housings that we have here.
Then of course in our economic development part, we have here at BGACDC, we have what we call the best food in town--it's called the BFT, best food in town. It provides some employment for persons working in the cafeteria type setting and of course we do serve the best food in town. Economic development also we provide in the summertime some jobs for youth in the summertime and for some middle-aged persons. We actually call it an intergenerational type of program in the summertime--we have college students and we have some youth that are still in high school who are 16 and maybe older, they work a summer program here at BGACDC, so those are some of our economic development type programs. Here in the youth and family service type program, we offer afterschool tutorial programs--we call it our Delta Reach and Teach Program.
Our Delta Reach and Teach Program is an afterschool program. It is also a - - program that we have and what we do there, we have some peer tutors and we have of course an - - that is a supervisor but we use high school students as peer tutors and we work with youth from ages of about 6 years old up to about 14, and so we have them come over after school in the evening time.
Our program this year--in the past we've been operating at five days a week but we took a unique approach this year, we're only operating three days a week because we are partnering with the Marvell school, the Marvell-Elaine school district and they are operating after school tutorial type programs Mondays and Tuesdays, and we operate Wednesdays and Thursdays, and so we took that approach that we might do a holistic approach to the students, and we call them scholars or the students to help them--we offer the same opportunities that they would have found in school. We have the same type of programs that we do in the afternoon that they would also go through at the school site.
So that's part of what we do in the youth and family services, and youth and family services also, we offer in the summertime, we're partnered with a couple of partners--USDA and FDA, we're partnered to do what we call the Delta Obesity Research Project, and the Delta Obesity Research Project, it is a project with some scholars or students and with their parents who--it's a volunteer-type project, and we have them assigned up and we are finding out some things about those of us who live here in the delta. We have also found in our Delta Research Project, we've found out that we're deficient in vitamin D.
Even though we have plenty of sunlight, but it appears that either we are not getting out in sunlight or we're staying in the house more, or we're not drinking that fortified milk with vitamin D in it, and so through our research project we have found out that in our area here, that vitamin D is one of our deficiencies so we'll work in our Delta Research Project trying to improve that by offering a program in the summertime where we offer kids some holistic meals, some nutrition-full meals, snacks, and of course some milk and things that have more vitamin D in it. That's one of our research projects. Go ahead.
From where you sit, you've been here for how long--
Six years.
Six years?
Mm-hmm.
Would you say that there's one person who played a key role in making this happen, getting this started?
There is. There is one person who is still with us who we call our ambassador, and that is Mrs. Gertrude Jackson. She is up in age, and I'm not going to tell you how old she is--I hope you don't film that, because I think I've really forgotten what actually her age is, but I know for sure she is in her 80s, for sure, and she has been here with us since the '70s, actually since about '78, '77 timeframe. She's been here the whole time working with us trying to make this community development center here, BGACDC, a viable part of the community and a necessity in the community. She has worked to do that. She is a person who goes out and presents BGACDC wherever her travels take her. She's one who's talking about BGACDC.
She and a couple of other community persons, one of them being Mr. Gale Thrower, he's no longer with us, he's passed on--the two of them take it on themselves along with some other community persons to establish this place here because they were looking for an opportunity in providing things for boys and girls in our community, and then of course they also said that they wanted adults involved so that's how we came up with the name Boys Girls Adults Community Development Center, because they looked at not only do we want your boys and girls but we also want you as a parent to be involved also, and so they came up with that slogan, that name to name this place.
At that time, they were just looking for an opportunity for persons in the community to have some place to go and something to do but as it developed and things began to progress, they began to take on more ideas, an idea of course having available affordable housing, an idea of also providing economic development for people in the community, so they began to develop and take on those ideas.
And what results do you see, what visible results?
Over the last 20 plus years, over the last 20 plus years this center has had a great impact in the lives of maybe some hundreds of young people and many of those young persons have went on from this place, some of them to become entrepreneurs themselves, some of them to become lawyers and doctors and to do well and they will tell you that it is because they were involved in some type of either boys program or girls program here at the center. We have a program called Girls Are Girls. We have a problem called Dad, which is dealing with boys, dealing with adolescent development, and those programs are programs that have been mentor programs that have helped some of those persons throughout their lives.
And we had just here recently in our banquet that we had just the other day, it was on November the 10th--we had one of our young persons who had grown up here at the BGACDC, to come back--Marcus Thrower. He is of course the son of Mr. Gale Thrower, but he is in Atlanta now and he is an investment consultant, so that's the type of quality of persons who have come through this place. We have several lawyers and maybe even a doctor that has come through this place.
Our executive director, one of her daughters is a lawyer who has come through BGACDC right here, so those are some of the positive things that this center has done, and even though those who may not have achieved that level of being a lawyer or a doctor or an investment banker and things of that nature, we have several educators who have traveled these halls here that we have here.
Mrs. Jackson is quite a dynamo and quite a source of inspiration. Can you remember specific times when she actually picked you up, brushed you off and moved you along?
Well, Mrs. Jackson likes to tell the story that she seen me speaking at a - - meeting one day and that she knew then that she had plans that I would become a person of interest to her, that she would have me working here at the BGACDC. Now, I say then, I said now, well, maybe I shouldn't have been up speaking so loud, she wouldn't have tried to put this here, this, the weight of doing this business on me, but I appreciate her having confidence in me and knowing that perhaps she could trust what she and other seniors had started some years ago, that she would look to say that she would want to trust that to a person like me.
What makes her so wonderful?
Well, I think it's her willingness to give 100% in whatever she's doing, and that she looks and sees the good in people and not necessarily the bad. I think that makes her a wonderful person. She can always find good in every person and believes that each individual has some good in them.
I think that's a wrap.
Okay.[applause][break in audio] MALE VOICE 1: Okay.
We're ready.
I just wanted to tell you all how when I first saw Reverend Turner, he's a little old boy--he looked like he'd just come out of college and he was at this meeting and he caught my eye. I went back home and told my husband, I said there was a young man at the meeting tonight and I didn't see him anymore until about 10 or 15 years later, right? And I said that's the man--that's the same one I saw at the meeting that night, and it turned out to be him and I knew he was going to be great. I told him, I said, I guess - - you stood out that night and I just couldn't forget him.
That's the man and I said I know he's good for us because God just put him in my eyesight because I don't know if I would have taken that much time just seeing people, a first impression when he was young and then I could just see something in him, and didn't see him no more until about 15 years later, he just got grown then. Okay, and that's all I wanted to say about Reverend Turner. And he just--and we're trying to get him to become, our director has gotten tired, she's just holding on, trying to get him to accept but he's doing fine. He's not sure he wants to take it all over and I wish I'd thought about it--I showed you our housing project. We came right back. Okay, so that's about it.
All right. Thank you so much.[break in audio]
We're just down the street from you. Tell us a little bit about how that came to be.
Well, when we got started, Mrs. Beatrice wanted housing. There were lots of little raggedy houses around her and Bea, that was the first thing she wanted, housing, and so we just went to work. They went to work on housing and went to FHA and that's who built them, FHA, and when we got it all set up, it took a long time, and once we got it, then you have to have open house, you know, let the community know what you're doing, and so that day there was packed out around here, and I come in that morning and all these white folks are there. They came in to stop it. They said they didn't want no housing project here because it brings drugs in the community, and so the mayor was a sweet little white lady--in other words, I won't go there, though.
But anyway, we had to overcome that. They were trying to stop it because a housing project wasn't good for a community, they say, but we wanted it. The first place we planned to put it, they weren't selling and so when the white folks decided to let us have it, it was way down on country road, back some woods, and FHA said no, we don't want to have a--they wanted it back and we wanted it on the highway where people can see it and that's how we got it, and that's about the gist of it, that we had to really fight to get to build it.
So how many years has it been in existence?
Right at when we about, about two years after we started, I think maybe, you know-I don't remember. It may be up--no, up there is when we started.
And this is housing for how many families?
I think it's 39 units. And I think we have 20 some units across town, you know. Okay, that's it.
Okay, thank you.
Mm-hmm.[break in audio] FEMALE VOICE 1: Let me know when you start and stop. MALE VOICE 1: We're stopping. I can't--what did you say?
We're starting. MALE VOICE 1: Okay, we're starting.
Okay, TJ, please tell us your name, who you are, where you live, what you do.
Theodore Eldridge Chilling [phonetic] here and I'm a grandson of Miss Gertrude Jackson. Her oldest daughter, Juanita, is my mother. I work for a USDA farm service agency now, and I actually work with all the farm commodity programs, disaster programs throughout Phillips County which is, since Miss Gertrude is a landowner, farmer out--I kind of oversee her land for the government as well. But it's kind of--I don't know what word I'm actually wanting right now, but my grandfather used to farm here and his brother, I guess at the age of 11, I was helping farm, per se.
It was more of a hobby for me, fun, because I got to drive tractors at a very young age and we spent a lot of time with my grandmother and grandfather spending the night, be at work, be ready to go like 5:30 in the morning, so I've been around farming a long time.
And say a little bit more about what it was like to be out working with your elders in the earth.
Yeah, I guess the main thing I can remember now--they were all great storytellers that kind of the reason I've heard a lot of the stories that Miss Gertrude has shared, I've heard variations or something about it, a lot of new stories also, but they were great storytellers and it never came off negative or someone did this or to me or we're victims. It was more like, this is just what happened. We woke up one day, this had happened and this is what we did to get over that, but it wasn't anything ugly or nasty about the stories that I heard as far as retaliation. That had just come with the times, so I kind of got their perspective as far as just another day.
So how do you think those stories shaped you, who you are and how you live your life?
Well, you know, not being a victim--you just go out and whatever you want, you make your own way. You ask anybody you think you need to for help, but you know, you're not really--or I don't per se wait or require any help, but I don't look at it as I can go talk to one person; I can't go talk to this group or that person. It's just, you get up, this is what you want to do, you go about it the best way you know how and whatever obstacle may get in your way, you just find your way around it. It's nothing to dwell on, per se.
What impact would you say your grandmother has had on this community?
Well, it's funny but I guess the awareness, per se, and the opportunity from the way she describes it nonchalantly, I had a thought to help kids but in that it's been hundreds and hundreds of kids and families that she's affected just from having the idea and then maybe someone taking her idea and building a wall, making it concrete, something that people can come to and anyone from the Marvell area that wants, you know, they might ask who am I and who's my family, so I can say well, my other--on my father's side, I'm an Eldridge, they may or may not know, but if I say I'm a Jackson, Gertrude Jackson--oh, yeah, we know her.
That's from the police, the mayor, state representatives all the way down, they know her and the family, and so just an awareness of :what she's done or been behind as far as community, everybody's aware of that.[background noise]
Absolutely.
What I want to say about the center--it's a meeting place. This meeting place we have here, like we passed - - the families come here and they have all the recreation here, just every holiday, it's just the only place and it'll be packed out, and our little ladies--you should have seen the decoration for, what's the night, Halloween?
Yeah.
Boy, they had the hair--but it was great and they wouldn't wait until night, they wanted to get it over at night before night, but it was just better--I wish they could have taken a picture of that. And every time they have different things, they decorate it different to meet the occasion but the only place we had a meeting, so I just wanted to say that it would be packed all around.
So without this place--
Oh, we wouldn't have any place to go.
No.
The only place.
And why is it so important for this community to have such a place?
Very important, because we wouldn't have anywhere except a school--then you have to pay to use the--because it was growing so until--and then, okay, let me tell this. They wouldn't have any parking place. We used to have parking place, but after the highway came through, couldn't park at all, couldn't but one car get out there, and so they just have all--I lost that thought, what I was going to say before that. But anyway, it's just a meeting place we have that wouldn't--we just wouldn't have places to meet. Didn't it seem like you started to ask me something?
How tight a community is this?
- - Turn in here.
It's not as tight as it needs to be, but this center is an example of when the community was tight and from Miss Gertrude having been one of the founders or one of the primary responsible parties for getting this center up, since everything that the minorities did had to come through here, there's the only place--they associate this place with her. But the community was tight as far as this is one example of when they came together and did something for themselves by themselves and it's still standing. I think because it's not--we're not tight now, we don't have any other place to go, this is still here and so it just shows us that we have a lot more work to do.
Okay.[background noise] MALE VOICE 1: - -
Good question. My colleague here is wondering is this community center played a role in starting community centers in other communities across and nearby.
I don't know. I don't know.
All right.
No, we don't have any other.
No, the West Helena area has a Boys & Girls Club, but it's maybe less than five years old, so this was the only center of its kind, per se--maybe a 25, even 50 mile radius. So I don't know how many of those cities actually came here, but the smaller communities, which used to be quite a nice population, they would all come here and especially like she say, when funerals, you've got reunions and everybody come back home, they come to the center.
Family reunions, whatever.
Yeah, so...
Okay, my friends. FEMALE VOICE 1: Reverend Turner has something to say.[background noise]
We could probably add to that question that you asked about us starting or being instrumental in other communities. And...[background noise]
Before we bring you up to take the mike, are there any questions you would like to pose to your grandmother about her specific, her personal work in the civil rights movement?
Well, did you enjoy it?
I really did.
Yeah.
It was just kind of like--I can't find the word, but it's just like, just out there, just in action--I enjoyed it. What's the word for that? It wasn't fear. I guess that's the most thing I could say--I would never fear for a friend.
I can personally say that I have never heard a negative story or anything about fear, it was almost like an afterthought because when you read your history books and because this story wasn't publicized in the area--I went to the Helena school district 20 miles away, we read in the history books. I'm like, my family went through that but it was an afterthought. I didn't know how serious it was because it wasn't talked to in the way that we have to be careful or this is what happened or you know, don't tell people who you are because of so-and-so.
We started the center and we helped people and you know, you don't get the gist of it, but this is going on when Martin Luther King and other people are dying for the very same things that they're going through but it just doesn't hit home as being nothing to fear or even worry about, per se. Just get up and go to the center.
Kind of like a fairytale.
Yeah, it was like a fairytale.
Okay. All right, thank you for that. Thank you so much.
I'm not ready that--to be taped.
You had a point that you wanted to make. FEMALE VOICE 1: The boys and girls club, or the community center that came out of or was influenced by this center.
Yeah. Well, yes, I do think that there are other centers that have been influenced from BGACDC. You have in Marianna, Arkansas, it's a center there and it's called the Lee County Community Development Center, I think it is, in Marianna. They were influenced and what I mean by influenced is because Mrs. Beatrice Shelby, executive director and Mrs. Gertrude Jackson have been influenced, have been some influential women in our community that other women in other communities have seen the things that they produced here in Marvell, and have begun to work in their communities to the same, and I would say that Marianna area which is in Lee County here in Arkansas, and then there are several areas over in Mississippi.
We were part of an Arkansas, Mississippi and a Louisiana collaborative one time, part of the Foundation of Midsouth, and so there were several other communities that were influenced by the things that had transpired right here in Marvell, Arkansas. Here in our recent, just a couple of years ago, our school system partnered--well, our school system had to take on another community. It used to just be the Marvell community and now it's the Marvell-Elaine community and so there are persons in Elaine now thinking about how they can have a community development center or some type of community center there in the Marvell area, so I would say that there are plenty of places that we have traveled around Arkansas and Louisiana and Mississippi and even maybe even in some other areas who have taken their thoughts from what we do right here at BGACDC.
And it's all because, like I say, we have a great ambassador in Mrs. Jackson and of course our executive director--when they go places they're always talking about BGACDC.
Wonderful. That's very helpful. Thank you.
Now you all see what the lord showed him to me when I was young. That boy is going to grow up and we're going to be.